pourquoi tu es au meeting d eric zemmour
pour des raisons très simples je fais
mon boulot de chroniqueurs politiques
bref eric zemmour est un ami je les dix
ans fois que je veux bien le dire une
101e fois le coq chante et 3 x 33 x 333
fois je ne renierai jamais mon amitié
avec eric zemmour et ensuite je pense
que c'était un événement politique très
important hier on connaît enfin le
programme d'eric zemmour c'est un des
principaux prétendants à la
présidentielle dont j'avais toutes les
raisons des clubs donc la polémique me
paraît surréaliste je voudrais eric que
tu réponds aux gens dont david qui a et
oui tu es qui a dit que tu étais pas
n'était pas dans le avec la région d'al
hira était au premier rang oui oui mais
je crois que les je crois que l'équipe
d'eric zemmour est au fait de mon amitié
avec le patron ils m'ont procuré une
place vip j'étais dans un jeu n'était
pas dans le coin des soutiens les
soutiens ils sont en face de la tribune
il se lève un par un ils prennent la
parole ils disent pourquoi ils
soutiennent m aurait ensuite comme il
est de coutume ils chantent la
marseillaise avec c'est moi je n'ai rien
fait de tout ça j'étais dans mon coin
j'avais des j'avais des photographes à
genoux devant moi parce qu'on était un
peu serré donc je ne faisais pas partie
des soutiens et je ne suis pas un
soutien d'eric zemmour je suis venu en
tant qu'ami et en tant que chroniqueur
politique je ne sais pas plus le meeting
pourtant il a réussi son premier meeting
sur la forme il l'a réussi il a fait des
progrès depuis depuis la convention de
la droite il a fait des progrès à l'oral
comme tribun qui sont très très
impressionnant après sur le fond
maintenant tout le monde peut se
déterminer par rapport à votre statut
vous sera pas pour eric zemmour moi je
suis pour le secret du vote c'est pour
ça que je crois que quand on vote c'est
déjà une petite pièce qui est fermée par
un rideau et je crois que ça corresponde
votera pas aujourd'hui à mélenchon je
voterai pas pour jean luc mélenchon au
statut d'icône à moi qu'il change
beaucoup à moins qu'ils changent
beaucoup d'ici la présidentielle mais
j'ai peu d'espoir david toi et à ta pas
arrêter toute la journée ça t'a rendu
fou qu'eric naulleau soit au meeting
d'eric zemmour non mais moi ça en fait
ça m'étonne pas mais vous noterez déjà
que ce soir eric naulleau qui disait
hier qu'il y aller en tant que
journaliste maintenant ai dit qu'il y va
en tant que chroniqueur et amis votre
version elle a changé parce que vous
savez trés la galerie j'emmène avec moi
c'est la même chose journalistes non
journalistes n'y a pas de journalistes
dans les meetings qui sont au premier
rang vip il ya avec l'eau sans rien sans
caméra sans rien juste un grand sourire
voilà ça n'existe pas les journalistes
caméra par ailleurs vous n'êtes pas ami
uniquement d'eric zemmour vous êtes amis
des gens dans la salle parce que vous
prenez des selphy avec eux d'accord donc
au bout d'un moment vous avez tenté de
nous faire croire que vous y était entré
en train de journaliste c'est pas vrai
vous étiez ça c'est un déguisement votre
déguisement de journalistes là il était
très mauvais on dirait qu'ils cotisent
déguisant petite fille là il était très
mauvais et maintenant ce qui convient de
dire c'est que vous êtes un de ses
soutiens politiques monsieur vous êtes
pas le changer un ami attendait un ami
un avis a dit nadine le soir avec son
pote nasa va passer meeting politique
c'est pas vrai nom maintient que tous
les gens qui veulent bien à celle fille
avez-vous en fac sont vos amis c'est
bizarre on doute on peut faire un petit
tour de table je vous assure on fait des
celle ci avec des génomes et conan alors
la garenne qui veut ravir le shérif sur
l'a10 les gens étaient très agréables
ensuite monsieur je vais je vais clore
le débat tout de suite je ne vous
reconnais pas le droit de me dire où je
peux m'asseoir et où je ne peux pas
m'asseoir ça tombe bien je n'ai pas le
droit de le dire si c'est au premier
rang ou au dernier rang et je ne vous
reconnais pas le droit ni à vous ni à
quiconque de m'expliquer comment je fais
mon métier donc le débat est clos je
m'offre 6 1 si je m'en fous si ça ne
vous plaît pas j'étais dans le carré
viiip il y avait un journaliste mois
dans le carré vieille mais aussi sa
double l'an passé votre logement vous
êtes tout le temps avec lui je dirais
même des sorties scolaires on voit votre
tête au milieu des gamins en vous êtes
tout le temps un mec eric des normes et
son soutien politique c'est au bout d'un
moment vous êtes vous avez la
chaussée que la scène à laquelle vous
faites allusion nous est en sursis
scolaire avec des diamants et rubis du
tout
une classe l'accompagnant de la classe
du nand à ce que zemmour pose avec les
enfants il insiste voilà moi pour faire
plaisir à séparer les gnons les virages
les oui mais oui mais au regard est non
vous n'êtes pas créés
parce qu'il suffit d'écouter eric
naulleau et le lire depuis 10 15 ans
pour savoir qu'il n'est pas d'accord
avec eric zemmour sur le fond
idéologique il le dit depuis 15 ans dix
ans sur l'émission
je le répète ici relisez les tweets de
d'eric naulleau c'est un homme de gauche
un homme de gauche maintenant il ya plus
de gauche de gauche de valenciennes
c'est un homme de la gauche à l'ancienne
qui n'est pas d'accord avec eric zemmour
sur la majorité des points pardon mais
qui a quand même le droit d'avoir une
amitié avec eric zemmour et devenir
hamiti je pense que avec naulleau n'est
pas d'accord avec ce qu'a dit eric
zemmour pendant son pendant son débat
pendant son disco mais il a quand même
le droit de venir sans se faire insulter
par toute l'extrême gauche ça me permet
d'ailleurs personne n'a parlé de
l'insulté c'est juste qu'enfin les
événements pourtant faut arrêter de se
prétendre de gauche quand on ne sait
jamais quelle est la mesure des dégâts
toujours défendu vivait sur nos locaux
vous avez toute votre carrière était
dans la roue de l'extrême droite vous
avez fait des choses avec avec alain
soral qui est quand même un antisémite
soi-disant néo nazis vous avez animé des
émissions avec eric zemmour tout ça a
une raison c'est parce que sans les
fachos vous n'êtes rien vous avez sorti
un livre en bulgarie vous avez fait un
flop votre livre il est mauvais et vous
êtes sur paris l'extrême droite oui sur
votre histoire ne vous devriez vous
devriez le widi soigner vos fiches parce
que là c'est la porte vous avez vous
avez jamais rien réussi sans l'extrême
droite c'est ça la vérité un ami de
votre parcours pour y aller mais jamais
rien jamais arrivées vont juste une
question et après vous fait passer je
suis ni juge st vous fait passer pour
quelqu'un de gauche monsieur on ne sait
pas quelles sont les propositions de
gauche que vous êtes vous essayer de
nous faire croire que vous êtes de
gauche n'a joué et fachos la nuit c'est
ça vous êtes comme madame doubtfire en
fait vous changer d'identité à chaque
fois pour être la caution de gauche
d'eric zemmour parce qu'on sait que vous
êtes au mode son soutien il y a personne
au monde qui ait autant porter la
contradiction à eric zemmour d une
émission à l'essai par ça il s'appelait
zemmour et naulleau qui était basée sur
la contradiction entre nous de
l'opposition entre nous deux c'est pas
vous étiez pendant ce temps là nous
n'étiez pas là alors celui posez vous
une question c'est comment la gauche on
est arrivé à l'état lamentable qui est
le sien aujourd'hui peut-être que les
gens de gens comme de gauche ont fait
alors tapis vous venait d'accepter ans à
l'union populaire monsieur bruno gaccio
auteur d'un livre religieux tout il a
fait un laser des problèmes mais là mon
livre avec soral est une engueulade sur
200 patientes s'est livré contre éric
mérite
mieux ils ont été des moments de
la vie des
citoyens qui a twitté hier pitoyable
eric naulleau après avoir publié un
livre avec un néonazi militants
antisémites et ce soir au premier rang
du meeting de zemmour au côté de
l'ancien secrétaire de le pen et madame
boutin le même ce qui sera d'être traité
de facho insultera la france a soumises
et prétendre à être de gauche si vous
lui répondez alexis corbière le
préfèrent accomplir mon travail de
journaliste au premier rang d'un meeting
plutôt que d' accomplir mon travail de
collabo au premier rang d'une
manifestation islamistes comme monsieur
corbières et ses amis et vous voulez
vous alors à la vie j'aimerais avoir les
défilés avec des islamistes